without the way thanks for sitting until
the end of the video i've been pull oh
crap i've started at the end again
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's not
backwards in coming forwards and
tomorrow i'll make the tenant video that
you're watching right now since august
i've done a ton of videos on the movie
and i've compiled the most asked
questions to clear up any confusion over
the film this includes why the future
version of the protagonist shot at
himself what the algorithm is why cat
didn't need a mask on the boat and a lot
lot more if this is your first time here
then please click the thumbs down button
and make sure you unsubscribe from the
channel to never see a video again
without the way cheers for clicking this
now let's get into the breakdown
okay so tenor opens with an opera scene
that pretty much throws you into the
movie at the deep end but what exactly
is going on here well on the surface it
seems like the protagonist is part of a
cia operation to infiltrate the opera
during a siege so that he can secure the
algorithm this fails and instead he's
drafted into the tenant organization
after being double-crossed having his
teeth pulled out and also choking down
on what he believes is a cyanide pill
sounds like my kind of night at the
opera but what exactly is going on here
well the protagonist was actually given
the intel for this job by the future
version of himself this was so that he
could not only ensure that he handed the
algorithm over to sator but also make it
so that he met neil and also showed he
was willing to lay down his life
just before the finale we learned from
eaves that the splendity mission is
meant to be one that no one returns from
eaves even says they can't afford having
anyone left alive who knows what the
algorithm is and the fact that the
protagonist takes this pill shows he's
willing to lay down everything if the
need calls for it this obviously will
heighten the trust that eaves has for
him and make sure that he picks him for
the job at the end now while the future
version made sure that sato was able to
collect the algorithm is hinted at by
priya who refuses to change telling his
past version about where it is
do try and keep up she says that they
actually need sator to bring all of the
pieces together so that they can then
snatch it and split it up the entire
point of the finale is to trick satyr
into believing that his mission in
burying the algorithm is successful so
that his past version won't change
anything if he thinks he's gonna win the
past sato will continue collecting the
pieces in order to bring them together
and carry out the plan that will allow
the algorithm to be stolen this is why
the tenant team want the explosion to go
off so that the past version of the
character believes his feature forces
are successful in the car chase we saw
how the antagonist learning the truth
about certain events helped him to play
them to his advantage and thus his past
version cannot know that he failed in
actuality the tenet team now have
everything they need to divide up the
algorithm and take it to their graves
but what is the algorithm exactly well
it's probably the plot point that we
learn the least about but from what we
discover we can piece certain things
together from priya we learn that the
algorithm was developed in the future by
scientists that discovered a way to
fully invade the world this would allow
things like global warming and climate
change to be reversed so that future
generations would not suffer the sins of
the past the algorithm is pretty much a
bomb that when detonated will cause a
massive spike in reverse radiation
across the planet that forces the past
to fold in on itself wiping out all life
beyond the consciousness of the future
the people of the future believe that it
is possible to change things in the past
whereas we learned throughout the film
that simply isn't the case however
because the people of the future always
try to change things they will always
make the algorithm and attempt to send
it back so we can see the events of the
movie play out the scientists that
created it realized that in destroying
the past they would destroy themselves
and there she separated the algorithm
and buried it which is where it was
found by saito upon believing that he's
won satos says that someday in the
future a man in a tower will flip a
switch and armageddon will be both
created and avoided now the armageddon
he's referring to is creating it in the
past in order to avoid it in the future
he believes that once the algorithm is
planted and then detonated that all life
in the past will be completely wiped out
however what the tenet team do is
basically along the same lines as the
scientists and they separate the
algorithm invert it and place it
somewhere so that it can never be found
by doing this at no point in the future
can these pieces of the algorithm be
brought together so therefore they can't
be used but who exactly is the scientist
well the movie tells us very very little
but as we only ever meet one scientist
and they happen to be a female i believe
that this is the same person that
becomes the oppenheimer of her time we
learn that laura has been studying the
reverse radiation for quite some time
and that though the people in the past
haven't figured out how to do it one day
they will i think that laura is actually
the person who'll discover the formula
for inverting things and the only time
we meet her she says that she was
assigned to the project and has been
studying it this close proximity to time
inverted objects makes her the perfect
person to figure it all out and though
we'll never know for definite movies
tend to give us the answers even if they
don't always point them out because this
is the only person we meet who fits the
role i think it's the case and if the
shoe fits
wear it i guess
also i'm good i was going to keep this
video really tenant and actually give
the answers before asking the questions
but i thought that would be too
confusing anyway just thought i'd add
that in there now this idea of
everything being pre-determined has put
a lot of people off the movie and made
them say what's the point well as neil
says before he goes to his death they
have faith in the laws of the universe
and by carrying out things the way
they're supposed to it shows that
there's actually a grand plan to it all
tenet is a fatalist film and i'm sure
many of us look back on bad things that
happened to us and see they actually led
to a positive outcome years down the
line which this film also seems to be
hinting at although lots of people die
along the way that doesn't mean that
tenet doesn't have somewhat of a happy
ending and though we don't know if the
protagonist goes off with cat and max at
the end i think the movie is hinting to
us that he does before going away for
the
last mission i'm not crying you're
crying
neil asks the protagonist if he's gonna
go back to london to check in on cat and
the protagonist replies by saying no
it's far too dangerous neil and says not
even from afar which the character also
denies however we know from the finale
that he did go back to london to check
in on her from afar so this was indeed a
lie now we've already done a big
breakdown on why we think that neil is
actually cat's son max which will be
linked at the end of the video but i
think neil asked these two specific
questions because he knows that the
protagonist did indeed meet the pair
after killing priya speaking of cat
there were several questions surrounding
why they didn't just hang around at the
turnstile after she was shot and then
revert her there however we do know that
before this moment sator's men owned it
so this would cause issues with the past
had they hung around they're only able
to move then and there because satoru is
out on the highway so they have to
travel back to the turnstile that they
know will be accessible at the airport
during their heist i've also had a lot
of people ask why cat didn't need to
wear a mask on the boat at the end i'm
never sure of exactly what bow they mean
as she's on several in the finale but if
it's the tenant one it's because she's
in a sealed room which has a regular
supply of oxygen a mask isn't needed at
that point and if they're talking about
when she's on satos it's because she's
reverted back to normal at this point so
isn't feeling the effects of time
invasion many of you wondered where cat
went after the boat scene at the end and
the simple answer is she hid away whilst
her past version continued on the same
path that she did all cat would have to
do is lie low until the inversion scene
in which that version of her goes to the
past and then she could pop out as there
were no duplicates and continue living
life like normal aware that she
succeeded and that her husband doesn't
exist beyond this point outside of the
airport the characters are actually very
good at avoiding themselves and we even
see that the protagonist passes the
windmill that he was in at the start of
the movie he's well aware that his past
self is hidden out of you and knows that
they won't come face to face even though
they're very close now the next question
is why can't anyone understand what
anyone is saying anytime in the movie
well that's because it was mixed during
the pandemic on some iphone headphones
and the score was so good that nolan had
them turn it up to 11.
based in the ride had the car go and
like now but seriously i have seen a lot
of people asking why the protagonist
shot at himself in the airport the first
time we see this fight it seemed like
the attacker is trying to kill him
however in hindsight we know that this
is actually the future version of the
character who's just trying to make it
to the turnstile the reason that he
fires the gun at his past self isn't to
kill him it's actually to unload the
entire thing so that it can't be used
against him from his pov we can clearly
see that he knows it won't hit his head
and thus he's deliberately missing on
purpose the past version even grabs it
from him at the end of the fight but
rather than trying to snatch it back he
just dismantles it to make sure no
matter what he won't be shot speaking of
turnstiles a lot of people are confused
about why people have to see themselves
exiting before going into it this is
simply because if they know they got out
the other side then they will always get
out but i don't think it's completely
imperative to their operation beyond
simply knowing that things will be okay
now most of the ops to do with the
turnstiles are led by eaves and many of
you have been asking who exactly he is
we don't actually know but we do know
that he was hired by tenet in order to
basically be the cavalry for the
protagonist at the turnstile and also be
the person that leads the final off eves
was clearly very close to the
protagonist if he was picked to be
someone who will guard the algorithm but
beyond that we know very little now that
is the main point of the movie and it is
said that the tenant operative should
know very little about each other which
is why we don't actually learn who he is
i think that's all the major questions
that i haven't cleared up in my previous
videos but obviously let me know below
if you have any more don't forget that
on the 30th of december we're giving
away three copies of the lord of the
rings 4k box set to our subscribers all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the movie the links to our socials are
in the description and you can also
support the channel by clicking the join
button and as a thank you you get videos
like this early if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of neil's timeline in
the film and also our 100 easter eggs
video which will be linked on screen
right now there's some of our best work
and the latter was featured in men's
health magazine so definitely check them
out after this without the way thank you
for sitting through the video i've been
poor and i'll see you next time take
care peace